[Music]
my job i enjoy it
very much my contribution conservation
it's something that makes me proud
working with rangers and patrols with
the guides
with animal trackers this is the best
office
in the world the growth
of the country and the energy it's
almost duplicated in
any other sphere of the society so like
coffee shops art centers
you feel that energy the energy the
creativity is part of
the whole fabric of society right now
it's a vibe
i'm trying to push the boundaries of
things which are made in rwanda
taking the inspiration from what we have
traditionally but make them more modern
my inspiration for my designs the
colorful patterns all over
rwanda in our tradition too i love to go
in the market and just watch people how
they combine colors
it's beautiful
young national park is a mountain
rainforest it's a park
rich in biodiversity we have 13 species
of primates
more than 300 species of birds and it's
where we have
the farthest source of the nile there is
something special that we need to
protect
i'm proud of my country because the
resilience and
willingness to work hard to learn from
each other
together we'll go further than if we
work individually
what's unique about random coffee is the
altitude the environment makes a huge
difference you get that smooth
refreshing taste and we have won
numerous awards
the past has a big influence also to how
i see
rwanda for example i use ignore the
traditional dancers it's beautiful
and it's gracefully so that's what i
wanted to explain it in my clothes it's
graceful but
strong at the same time
[Music]
there's a word that we use called
agachiro agatchiro means the idea of
self-worth
self-respect and it translates in
everything that we do
means the dignity of rwandans working
together
put efforts together it makes me proud
to be
rwandan
[Applause]
agathiro for me it's a very powerful
word which has so much
meaning be grateful be respectful be
resilient be an example
there is a new change there is a new
render
being created and i'm part of it
there's an energy that's out there
welcoming every single person come visit
rwanda walk the street talk to the
people
you'll you'll be amazed what you
discover rwanda
is is a land of dreams